Pennsylvania judge could decide today
whether 12 former Penn State fraternity
brothers will stand trial in the death
of a student after a hazing ritual
sophomore Timothy Piazza died last year
from injuries after prosecutors say he
had 18 drinks in 82 minutes in all 26
former Beta Theta Pi members have been
charged but several charges have been
thrown out yesterday prosecutors
recommended dropping more charges but
reinstating others Don Dahler is outside
the court house in Bellefonte
Pennsylvania to help us sort through it
all Don good morning good morning this
process has dragged on for months in
fact this is the fourth time prosecutors
have tried to get this in front of a
jury but the Attorney General says a
review of the case by his office leads
him to believe that there might finally
be justice for the Piazza family we are
committed to holding every responsible
individual accountable for their actions
in this tragedy Pennsylvania Attorney
General Josh Shapiro said Tuesday he
wants to appeal to reinstate involuntary
manslaughter charges against five of the
26 former fraternity members allegedly
involved in Timothy piazzas death
the more serious charges have been
dismissed twice before Y continue after
this we don't think that a local Majesty
judge should have the final say we think
that a jury should have the final say
Shapiro says the state's case is based
on three things that the defendants
participated in the alcohol based hazing
ritual were aware that Piazza had fallen
and failed to get him medical attention
which could have saved his life the
defendants have denied all charges three
of their lawyers told CBS News in
separate statements that they are
disappointed by this appeal defendant
Luke Visser's attorney said this fourth
attempt to bring serious charges against
his client is legally without merit on
abuse of the legal system and should be
denied no one's child should be hurt or
died from just trying to join an
organization Timothy's father Jim was at
yesterday's press conference and is
hopeful about the appeal we don't want
it to happen to anyone else
beyond justice we're hoping that
does you know create a cultural change
in Greek life in particular but also
another organization such that hazing is
simply eradicated and done away with the
more serious charges are expected to be
dropped against most of the defendants
here today although they will be brought
up on lesser charges the Attorney
General says as for the five for whom he
wants the involuntary manslaughter
charges to be reinstated he says if his
appeal fails he's going to take it to
Superior Courts biana
keep on fighting Don thank you